Speaker 1: MAGA is indeed melting down today,
the day of Donald Trump's second arrest and
indictment. This one federally in Miami,
Florida. By the time you listen to today's show,
it may have already happened. And we will, of
course, have full live coverage today as well as
of Trump's Bedminster speech at 8:15 p.m. Eastern
tonight. Hope you'll join me for that and then we
will debrief tomorrow. But let's take a quick
tour through MAGA land. Here is a former Trump
propagandist, Steve Bannon, who recently attacked
me and called me brother Dave Pacman. This guy is
not my brother. He is now turning on William Barr,
William Barr, Trump's former attorney general, of
course, saying if half of the indictment is true,
Trump is toast. We looked at that clip yesterday
and here is Steve Bannon. He's using profanity,
guys. So that's how you know he means business.
Speaker 3: And Bill Barr, you can sit up there
and say, it's a great case. We're going to
shove this up your ass, okay? We're going to
shove it up your ass. You are frickin guilty
of treason big over there. You are guilty
of treason and Ray's guilty of treason.
Speaker 1: There is no evidence whatsoever that
William Barr has committed treason. There is no
evidence whatsoever that FBI director chosen by
Trump Christopher Wray has committed treason. And
I will remind you, one of the big selling points
that Trump listed about himself was that he would
hire the best people, always the best people.
And he hired two traitors. He hired William Barr,
a traitor, and Christopher Wray a traitor. It
doesn't say very much about Trump's ability to
select employees, which was one of the big
selling points. We go now from Steve Bannon
to Carrie Lake. Carrie Lake is also using an
extreme filter on her camera. She is talking
about how the NRA comments she made, how there
are NHRA members who will stand between, I guess,
the Justice Department and Trump. It's
not a threat. She says. It's not a threat.
Sure sounds like a threat to me. Take a listen.
Speaker 2: If they think they're going to hurt,
lay a finger on our president, President Trump,
They're going to have to come through me. And I
made a mistake. I said 75 million others just like
me. I think it's more like 300 million others just
like me. People in this country who support there.
Speaker 1: Aren't even 300 million adults in
the United States. What is she talking about it?
Speaker 2: Trump Who know what's up? Who know that
that botched election was an attempt to prevent
him from getting in office and cleaning up the
corruption in our country. And I said I said as an
aside, and most of us are not members. That is not
a threat. That is a public service announcement.
Speaker 1: It certainly sounds like a threat. And
if you want to see exactly what it leads
to. Freedom News that TV interviewed Pat,
a Trump supporter, who said January 6th is
going to look like a playground compared to,
I guess, what he's willing to do in Miami later
today. This is serious, folks. Listen to this.
Speaker 4: A lot of my family blood spilled
for this country. I'm not going to let it go
to waste. I'm not I refuse. I did 19 years
here as a federal agent in Dade County.
I'm just not going to let this country go to
waste. And right now, it's going to waste. Well,
if he gets indoctrinated, January six
is going to look like a playground.
Speaker 1: I assume he means indicted. I assume
when Pat says indoctrinated, he means indicted.
Speaker 4: It's going to look like a playground
from the inside voices that I hear from all the
militias and everything else. It's going to
be a playground. But if they want to fight,
bring it. I mean, I've been in I watched Kamala
Harris in Orlando. I watched Antifa throw bottles,
spit on my child, throw stuff at us. They told us
to refrain ourselves. Really? What? Okay. But it
is what it is. You know this country so left right
now. But we've got to bring it back to the right.
We got to get right on the right path. We got to
bring everything back. If we don't, we're going to
crumble. We're going to be a third world nation.
Speaker 1: When I'm telling you guys,
when the world sees this, this will lead to
our viewers from Germany and from the UK and
from France and from Finland and from Sweden that
I'm going to get an email saying, David, what is
wrong with the country? What is happening there?
Speaker 4: We have to stand up for that flag. We
have to stand up for our beliefs and we got to put
God back in this country. If we forget about him,
he's going to forget about us. And right now,
we're forgetting him and we're forgetting Israel.
We forget both of those. Read your Bible. Read
your Bible because there's a lot of boys like
me that are ready. All we need is an order.
Speaker 1: We're ready to leave everything they
need in order. And they are ready. Here's one
more person they're talking to, I guess, but.
Okay. No, they're not. Okay. That's the end of
the interview. Let's hope for no violence today.
That is my hope. The last thing we
need on top of any of this is to cloud.
What should be apolitical. Justice Department
actions and court cases with the violence of
these unhinged people. That's my hope
that we do not see violence today.